merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur a été très clair sur le
dispositif carrière long qui est
extrêmement complexe tout le monde tout
le monde a pu le voir je voudrais
simplement commencer par une deux
précisions de méthode à l'attention de
Madame ponce vous avez dit madame la
sénatrice que le gouvernement avait
déposé deux amendements sur les
carrières longues pourraient tout à fait
exact le gouvernement a déposé le mardi
soir de la deuxième semaine de débat un
amendement identique aux amendements 45
1918 et 3407 visant à autoriser la
création d'une quatrième borne d'âge
ensuite à l'occasion du débat du
vendredi a été évoqué les pistes de
travail sur la question de la durée de
cotisation mais aucun amendement n'a été
déposé la deuxième précision que je veux
apporter concerne un propos où vous avez
eu toujours sur la méthode où vous nous
avez dit Madame
puisque c'était déposé dans le cadre du
47 tiréol le gouvernement aurait pu le
mettre dans le texte ce n'est pas le cas
ce n'est pas le cas puisque l'article
47-1 de la Constitution et la loi
organique qui le décline disent que le
gouvernement en cas de d'impossibilité
d'une des assemblée à aller au bout de
l'examen du texte transmet à l'autre
assemblée son projet de loi initiale
auquel il peut ajouter les amendements
de son choix mais à condition que ces
amendements étaient adoptés par
l'Assemblée saisie du texte dans la
mesure où l'amendement déposé le mardi
je parle de l'identique aux 45 1918 et
34 07 était déposé à l'article 8 que
l'Assemblée nationale n'a jamais
examinée n'a pas été adopté et donc le
47 terrain interdit au gouvernement de
le mettre dans le texte qu'il vous a qui
vous a transmis sur les différents
amendements il y a un propos général que
je veux faire avant de donner un avis
pour chacun en essayant d'être aussi
méthodique que la présidente de séance
le souhaite
le premier le point général concerne les
questions de coût puisque les
dispositifs de carrière longue au-delà
leur complexité de mise en oeuvre sont
des dispositifs qui sont coûteux si nous
retenons un principe qui consiste à dire
tout assuré qui a travaillé au moins un
trimestre avant l'année de ses 21 ans
était ligible carrière longue nous
sommes sur un coup qui est supérieur à 2
milliards d'euros
si nous disons c'est ce que Monsieur
salvo Delhi a proposé il y a un instant
de qui consiste à dire la durée des 43
ans non seulement supplante la question
de l'âge d'ouverture des droits mais en
plus doit intégrer non seulement les
trimestres cotisés mais aussi les
trimestres valides c'est ce qui a été
proposé par Monsieur le Sénateur
salvadelli nous sommes sur un coup à 7
milliards d'euros et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne l'avons pas
retenu si nous indiquons que tout assuré
qui a commencé à travailler avant des
bornes d'âge à hauteur de 5 trimestres
mais sans aucune
autre condition que d'atteindre 43 ans
nous sommes sur un coup qui est très
supérieur à un milliard et demi d'euros
et enfin si nous disons c'est ce que
disent les amendements qui arrivent à la
fin de l'allias pardonnez-moi j'en ai
oublié le numéro les trois la maman 3103
et 3126 qui consiste à dire
par rapport à la situation existante où
il y a trois critères cumulatifs le fait
d'avoir tricotisé cinq trimestres avant
une borne d'âge le fait d'avoir atteint
un âge spécifique d'ouverture des droits
et le fait de se dispenser du troisième
critère qui est celui d'une durée de
cotisation nous sommes sur un coup qui
est supérieur à 300 millions d'euros
c'est l'état d'esprit de ce qui avait
été discuté le vendredi en fin
d'après-midi à l'Assemblée nationale et
donc pour ces raisons là j'appelle le
Sénat à faire preuve de beaucoup
d'attention parce que nous avons souvent
évoqué la nécessité de retrouver
l'équilibre budgétaire et donc financier
du système de retraite et l'addition des
mesures votées je pense par exemple à la
mesure extrêmement utile j'ai de
l'analyse favorable concernant la
surcote qui représente elle aussi 300
millions d'euros font que cette
perspective d'équilibre s'éloignerait en
2030 et je pense qu'il serait
extrêmement négatif d'avoir une réforme
qui permet d'améliorer les choses mais
qui ne nous permettent pas d'atteindre
l'équilibre en 2030
[Musique]